not only am I going to review an older
movie for you guys but I'm gonna review
one of my favorite movies as in like
ever Terminator 2 Judgment Day I know
what some of you are thinking right now
you're like wait Terminator 2 worst
Terminator 1 I wanted to go straight for
the throat on this one I wanted to
review one of my favorite movies of all
time but I'm not gonna leave you hanging
here's a bit of the backstory in
Terminator lore on August 29th 1997 the
machines we created became self-aware
and they pretty much wipe out mankind
yeah it didn't quite happen but you know
from that point to the Year 2029
mankind's been locked in a war with the
machines the leader of this resistance
is a man named John Connor he actually
leads mankind to victory so in
Terminator 1 the machines send a machine
back in time to kill Sarah Connor
ya know Sarah Connor means no John
Connor means the machines win and now we
reach Terminator 2 machines kind of had
a fail-safe actually sent two
terminators back through time one back
to the 80s to take out Sarah Connor the
other to the 90s to take out John Connor
but don't worry we humans were smart and
we have a plan John Connor from the
feature reprograms the Terminator to
protect him as a child in the 90s now we
have our movie and it's awesome there's
so much I like about Terminator 2 one
it's exciting as hell in the first movie
you have a soldier who's protecting
Sarah Connor from a terminator so they
can't really scrap in that movie a hand
hand fight will be like terminator go
boom well there's his head he's dead I
win but in Terminator 2 you have Arnold
Schwarzenegger a t800 machine same model
this in Terminator 1 and you have Robert
Patrick playing the t1000 so you can
have them throw each other through walls
and they're not going to die from it
you're just going to be absurdly
entertained by it and as for the t1000
the t1000 in Terminator 2 remains one of
the deadliest bastards ever put in a
movie this guy was just death incarnate
and he was revolutionary for the time
he's made completely out of liquid metal
so he can change his appearance he can
look like anyone can turn his arms into
knives and stabbing weapons I know that
is common now you're like I've seen that
before but in 1991 that was absurd that
hadn't been done before after you
watched Terminator 2 Judgment Day t1000
is in your mind you go to anyone you're
like oh I conic t1000 moment they're
like I have to pick one there's a scene
where he gets frozen liquid nitrogen
he's walking towards John Connor and
he's just like not stopping but he's
slowly freezing Arnold's all like hasta
LaVista baby that's like a staple cinema
moment right there and what the t1000
does in Terminator 2 remains to
this day the coolest stuff any liquid
metal Bing has ever done in a movie and
the excitement in this movie never stops
like Arnold Schwarzenegger and t1000
fight in a mall then t1000 chases John
Connor on foot then he gets in a semi
and he's going after John Connor on his
little motorcycle then Arnold's pursuing
the semi on his motorcycle trying to get
to John Connor it's just one of the many
action sequences in Terminator 2 they're
just like dude that's just the best and
above it being exciting and having this
revolutionary t1000 character the human
characters themselves are deeper in
Terminator 1 Kyle Reese the soldier
who's protecting Sarah Connor kind of
burdened her with knowledge and let her
know that the human race is going to be
incinerated and machines are going to
take over the world and she let that
slip to a few people now people think
she's crazy so she's in a mental
institution and she is not the Sarah
Connor from Terminator 1t1 she's Suzy
homemaker she's a waitress she's like
I'm no one special now for the past
decade she's been training doing
push-ups becoming all hardcore she's
actually quite the badass in Terminator
2 she's not Suzy homemaker she's Suzy
kill you with my pinky she's nuts man
and in the world of Terminator 2 being a
little deeper than you think it might be
there's a scene where Sarah Connor
learns about the guy who's going to
ultimately cause Judgment Day so she
goes on a quest to wipe this guy out I
mean why not she kills him she changes
the future the robots never take over at
that point she's a terminator to this
guy she might not be a machine like the
other terminators but she's on a quest
to kill someone to change the future I
just I like that little detail and to
any and all you girls out there who are
like Terminator 2 I denies a guy movies
this guy movie here's a story true story
I knew this girl who said the same thing
she's like I have no interest in
Terminator 2 is a guy movie what would I
like about it I loaned her my copy I was
like watch it I will bet you that you
will love it not only will you love it
you might even cry at the end I still
dude man tears at the end seriously she
returned it she was like oh my god it
was so good just you were just right it
was so good yeah I don't mess around
about that [ __ ] Terminator 2 Judgment
Day ends Terminator lore for me The
Terminator saga is Terminator 1 and
Terminator 2 after that nothing is canon
it'll be light entertainment at best but
in the end it ends at Terminator 2 and
in Terminator 2 being one of my favorite
movies of all time if I were to make a
top 10 list it has to be on there
somewhere
Terminator 2 Judgment Day is awesome
tacular
if someone had a gun to my head was like
best Cameron movie ever you have to say
one I'll be like ot to definitely and
I'm pretty sure I would live through the
situation so your favorite Terminator
movie out there you gotta have one
what is it comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more hasta LaVista
baby